we finished the last video with the
assassination of julius caesar on the
ides of march march 15 44 bce and you
might remember it was the it was it was
done by factions opposed to julius
caesar who thought that one he had
gotten too much power but even more he
was using that power to in a lot of ways
at least from their point of view
undermine their authority that he was a
populist and as a populist he was
undermining the power of the aristocracy
and so they get together and they
assassinate him now you can imagine that
all sorts of turmoil emerges from that
at the time of the assassination julius
caesar and mark anthony are
co-consuls you might remember mark
anthony from the previous video one of
julius caesar's generals in gaul he was
also put in charge of the italian
peninsula when julius caesar went to go
and take on his opponents take on pompey
in greece
and so mark anthony is the remaining
consul and he says well what what do i
do do i immediately try to punish these
conspirators in particular you have
brutus
brutus and cassius who are considered
two of the leaders of the conspiracy and
he decides instead of putting the the
senate into further turmoil he tries to
have a little bit of a compromise and
doesn't immediately punish them and
they're able to go from rome and then go
to the east where they are the de facto
leaders of the eastern of the eastern
provinces
but then in 43
bce
things get a little bit more interesting
julius caesar in his will
he declares that his nephew
octavian or will be shortly known as
octavian who's 18 years old at the time
of the death on the ides of march that
he is that he in his will should be his
adopted son and so makes him the natural
heir of julius caesar
now anthony who's also one of julius
caesar's right-hand man throughout and
his one of his strong supporters as he
came to power he also
in a lot of ways could have claimed well
i i have some rights here to to some of
the power that julius caesar has gotten
and then there was a third figure
lepidus and this is a picture of him
right over here this is actually a
picture of the three this is mark antony
this is octavian and this is lepidus and
lepidus was also a significant supporter
of julius caesar so the three of them
get together and this is lepidus
timeline right over here each of these
timelines show the lifespans of these
characters so you can see when they were
born when they die to get a sense of
their ages and and when they and when
they happen to to pass away
and so these three characters get
together and they form a triumvirate and
this triumvirate is called the second
triumvirate because you might have
remembered the first triumvirate between
julius caesar pompey and crassus and
that was an informal agreement this one
is actually gets legal backing and not
only do they form this triumvirate but
they're given incredibly powerful
power over the roman republic and they
decide to go after the conspirators
so in
sorry so in 42 i know what my brain is
doing in 4 43 the triumvirate is formed
and so in 42 they eventually are able to
meet the conspirators who killed julius
caesar and they meet them at the battle
of philippi which is right over let me
do this in color you can see the battle
of philippi where they're able to defeat
the conspirators
so after the defeat of the conspirators
they essentially divide the the republic
although it really is an empire they
divide the republic between them
anthony mark anthony
he becomes the ruler the de facto ruler
of the east
mark and he becomes a de facto ruler of
the east and then he actually is the
nominal ruler over gaul as well but then
he put someone else in charge there and
as we'll see over the course of this 17
this to this this tumultuous 17-year
period mark anthony really has a lot of
his control and influence in the east
but they've essentially split the empire
between the three of them and right at
that split octavian doesn't get so much
of the empire but we'll see that'll
change shortly where he's able to be in
control of the western half of the
empire in a matter of a few years so
after that
then in 41 and this is where
cleopatra enters into the picture and
she always makes this a little bit more
colorful
mark antony decides to that he wants to
meet with cleopatra so he's
now leading the east he starts leading
it from athens then he moves where he
governs from to ephesus
and he calls cleopatra to and he already
knows her he's met her several times to
come meet him here in tarsus
and here in tarsus and then they go back
to alexandria a romance starts between
mark anthony and cleopatra one of the
most famous romances in all of history
remember this is the same cleopatra who
had a romance and a child likely through
julius caesar and anthony mark anthony
and cleopatra will actually have three
children together two of which were
conceived in this time period right over
here this this period of round 41 bce
so this is where
we are
on the timeline
right over there but then in 40 bce the
parthians invade
and you might remember the parthians
this is another very significant you
really can consider them a pure empire
to the romans on this map you're only
seeing the very left or the most
westward tip of the parthian empire they
had control of when you remember the
keamanid empire the seleucid empire of
most of persia they are a significant
empire that was really a check on
ancient rome and so they decide to
invade
they decide to invade and the romans
already have trouble with the parthians
you might remember
crassus one of the first three triumvirs
members of the triumvirate he went and
while fighting the parthians that's
where he was killed and so the romans
have had some interest in going after
them and now you have the parthians who
are taking it to the romans they're
they've taken it on the offense so
anthony he's go goes from his when he
finds out about this and he's he's
apparently in charge of the east so it's
a bit of an embarrassment for him he
goes to tyre which is the remaining
significant holding that the romans have
while he's entire he finds out that his
wife he does have a wife so this this
thing that he has with cleopatra is
really an affair his wife is embroiled
in a civil war with octavian and the
civil war and you'll see there's a just
general issue throughout the the
especially the later part stages of the
roman republic
and even the roman empire that as rome
expands it needs these armies and one of
the things that they promised these
soldiers are hey after you serve when
you're a veteran we're going to give you
some land so you could be a nice farmer
or at least landlord other people might
do the the farming and we'll probably
you know and you can have slaves and all
the rest
now in order to keep doing that you keep
needing new land so octavian in order to
make some of these veterans happy were
was was giving away land some of which
was already i guess you say owned by
existing romans and so i so mark
anthony's wife was using that really as
a as an excuse to try to vie for power
and just to be clear even though there
was this triumvirate between octavian
antony and lepidus things were tense
from the beginning between antony and
octavian both of them
both of them saw themselves as natural
heirs to julius caesar anthony says hey
this young little 18 year old upstart
what has he done to deserve this empire
i've been i've been beside julius caesar
the entire time octavian's here saying
hey i am now officially julius caesar's
adopted son he takes on the name caesar
i am the rightful heir to julius
caesar's power
and so sitting here in tyre
the antony decides okay let me go let me
go take on octavian
so he takes he decides to go and lay
siege to brandisium
in order to defend his wife even though
he obviously wasn't didn't care too much
about his his wife's honor
as over there they're they're
essentially at loggerheads he he tries
to go into the civil war his wife
anthony's wife dies
octavian and ante decide okay maybe
maybe we should not be fighting each
other uh so much and so they descend
they decide once again to be friends and
then they really at that point decide to
split the empire more formally between
east and west where in the triumvirate
you have marc anthony still getting the
east
you have octavian
being in control of the west including
including the italian peninsula and then
lepidus gets africa
and you have lepidus getting africa
right over here
so i'll leave you in it i'll leave you
with that there's a little moment of it
looks like a little bit of peace between
mark ante mark anthony and octavian but
as we'll see in the next video it's
about to get a lot worse the big picture
from here is that they were able to take
care of the conspirators but now they're
starting to squabble the triumvirate is
starting to squabble especially mark
antony octavian lepidus was always kind
of the i guess you could say the third
wheel here was always between anthony
and octavian cleopatra has now has a
romantic relationship with anthony she's
aligned with antony
at the same time remember cleopatra
she's considered the richest woman in
the world at this time she is the
pharaoh of egypt and remember egypt even
though the people were egyptian
cleopatra is part of the ptolemaic
dynasty she is greek but what makes her
interesting is that she takes on a lot
of the trappings and she learns to speak
egyptian so she's actually quite popular
from a i guess relatively speaking terms
with the egyptian people and the other
thing to keep in mind is if these
parthians these parthians have just
laid another insult on the romans right
over here when they invaded syria and
able to take over this territory and
this is especially annoying to mark
anthony who's supposed to be in charge
of the east